انتظر انتظر انتظر انتظر دور نفسك
ابتعدنا ذهبنا بعيدا
[موسيقى]
السويدية في أوروبا
وقعت على أنها الحرية والديمقراطية
كتابنا الأعلى القرآن
إذن ليتم حرقه من قبل الشرطة
إنه وصمة عار أن تفعل ذلك
[موسيقى]
من دولتنا
طلبنا من رئيسنا السويد
قطع كل العلاقات مع الحكومة
انظروا ، يريدون الانضمام إلى حلف الناتو ، أيها الأوغاد و
مهد المنظمات الإرهابية
دولة لحلف شمال الأطلسي ، حيث نحن أيضا
تركيا تريد الدخول أكثر من اللازم
هناك فرصة عظيمة
لا ينبغي
[تصفيق]
على النحو المصرح به من قبل السلطات السويدية
هذا استفزازي أمام السفارة
تحقيق العمل في جميع أنحاء العالم
المسلمون في جميع أنحاء العالم
الشباب
في جميع أنحاء العالم ليغضب
هذا سوف يزعج المسلمين.
توافق على السماح
ليس من الممكن لهذا
تركيا من أجل تحقيق هذا العمل.
إنها صدفة أن يتم اختيار السفير.
لا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]